هل سبق لك ان سمعت عن سمكه تستطيع تغيير
جنسها من انثى الى ذكر هذا الامر سيحيرك
للوهله الاولى كما حير على العديد من
العلماء مكه تعرف باسم نابليون وتعتبر
واحد اغلى الاسماك في العالم وهي مهدده
بالانقراض السمكه تعيش في البحر الاحمر
ويصل
متوسطين عاما
[موسيقى]
اوقفت الشرطه الامريكيه موكب عريس يمني
وقيادته هو وكل من كان يرافقه بعد بلاغ
امني يفيد بوجود قناص في المكان لكن سرعان
ما تم فك قيدهم وتبين انها احتفالات زفاف
باللباس اليمني التقليدي ولاحقا التقط
التقطت عناصر الشرطه الامريكيه صورا
تذكاريه معهم
[موسيقى]
ليس من الغريب ان الكثير من الاشخاص
اصبحوا مدمنين على تصفح هواتفهم المحموله
ولا يمكنهم ايقاف انفسهم بغض النظر عما
يفعلونه ومنهم هذا العريس الذي ظل يستخدم
هاتفه المحمول اثناء زفافه ولم يعر عروسه
اي اهتمام الانتقادات هاله عليها على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وتسائل كثيرون ما
هو المهم جدا الذي شغل العريس في هذه
المناسبه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في ظاهره غير مسبوقه تداولت مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي في تونس صورا ومقاطع فيديو
لشواطئ في الضحيه الجنوبيه للعاصمه تظهر
تغير لون البحر من الابيض الى الاخضر في
مشهد اثار مخاوف من تعرض المنطقه للتلوث
وكشفت وزاره الفلاحه والصيد والبحري انها
اجرى التحاليل مجهريه اظهرت ان سبب سبب
تغيير لون المياه هو تكاثر الطحالب
الدقيقه
اخضر ولا عيني معنا
بحر اخضر اخضر هذيك
حاله ولاده تحدث مره في المليون ام
بريطانيا تصاب بصدمه ولدت توامين الاول
ببشره بيضاء وثاني ببشره سمراء الاول
عيونه ملونه وثاني عيونه بنيه وسائل اعلام
ذكرت ان ان اصدقاء الاسره كانوا يتساءلون
ما اذا كان الطفلان توامين فعلا الجواب
العلمي هو ان الامر طبيعي لكنه نادر جدا
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء اليوم لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات